l'autonomie alimentaire ça peut être un
choix de société une politique claire
mais ça peut être aussi un choix
personnel projet familial alors qu'on
s'arrache les semences et les poules
pondeuses
il est encore trop tôt pour dire si la
coved 19 marquera un tournant
mais pour certains l'autosuffisance
c'est déjà un mode de vie
présentement
c'est tranquille c'est tellement calme
[Musique]
fait moins de dégâts
je comprends que c'est une crise
planétaire puis ça va pas au pied d'un
déplacer ce qu'on voit là en images mais
si on est vraiment dans une bulle
quatre ans ton p'tit bal à survenir en
chef brasse et de haut en bas
entre écoles fermées et pose de la
société robin leblanc profite du temps
qui lui est donné avec ses enfants et
aujourd'hui il leur apprend à faire du
fromage
les filles n'ont pas d'activité vont pas
nulle part faire du socle ça fait qu'on
a du temps on se dit le siphon reste en
quarantaine
on est aussi plein de projets parce que
l'offre faire du sirop d'érable l'été
s'en vient on commence nos plantes son
intérieur ex on peut faire ça avec les
enfants aussi dans un précédent
reportage nous avions présenté la
réussite de ce couple de bathurst 100%
au tout suffisant moi c'est mes filles
que j'ai donné un roumain âgé dimanche
leur poche sans manger des carottes et
des navets et donc réduit ça l'a poussé
à farouk mails pour la satisfaire va
falloir que ça soit diversifiée
au départ l'objectif c'est d'avoir des
légumes à l'année grâce à une serre de
grands jardins de nombreux arbres
fruitiers
ils ont produit toute une variété de
fruits et légumes mon congélateur était
rempli de cantaloup en a même en des
poires en indice des pruniers on a des
premiers bien sur des camry et bleuets
les fraises et framboises avec de
nombreux animaux de ferme
robin leblanc fabrique divers produits
laitiers confection des pâtes et des
saucisses les huiles décide
bref tout je reviens pas qu'on puisse
faire tout seul pick up bien vif qu'on
ait de la nourriture qui rendra les
congélateurs pendant qu'il nous en reste
encore l'année d'avant
[Musique]
aujourd'hui en pleine crise le couple
vit des bénéfices du travail passé la
maison est remplie de nourriture
conserve le matin on a du pain de la
farine on a des grains on aurait côté du
seigle cet été on peut faire ça me faire
différents types de pain on a toujours
aux mains des jeunes et nos dîners on a
tellement mis deux choses en concert des
mêmes gestes et ratatouille
c'est clair qu'on est chanceux parce que
nous n'obtenions dans la façon il est
très courte
je n'ai pas été obligés de faire des
provisions pâte à choux de carottes
cette réussite en inspirer plus d'un
dont rachel farmer et grégory lemoine de
st zéphirin de courval près de
drummondville
tu t'assois pour manger puis tu dis on
regarde c'est moi qui a produit tous
tout ce qu'il y avait dans mon assiette
c'est vraiment un sentiment
d'accomplissement qui ne pousse à
continuer cela fait maintenant trois ans
qu'ils ont débuté leur projet
d'autonomie alimentaire et ici aussi les
tracas de la crise de la coved 19 semble
bien loin on continue le train quotidien
chaque matin et chaque soir les animaux
ont besoin d'être soignés on continue on
continue le jardin il faut être plantés
comme d'habitude donc c'est vraiment
c'est quelque chose de spécial parce
qu'on lit les nouvelles depuis d'un côté
on voit qui est vraiment quelque chose
qui se passe mais on le ressent pas
avec des vaches des poules et un jardin
de plus en plus grands le couple vise à
atteindre ce qu'ont réussi robin rebecca
au nouveau brunswick
peut-être qu'un jour on va l'atteindre
mais on reste réaliste dans le sens que
on travaille on a des job à temps plein
on a des enfants c'est quand même il
faut être réaliste pour le moment pour
dire on peut pas tout faire en même
temps mais ça nous pose chaque année
aller plus loin
sachant que ce sera jamais possible
autrement pour s'approcher de la
perfection
or si la perfection je pense que vous
pouvez peut-être pas pour tout le monde
mais pour nous ce serait la perfection
parce que ce serait vraiment de dire qu
on peut tout faire on sait tout faire on
a appris à tout faire et que on est
capable de se nourrir nourrir notre
famille et même de nourrir notre
entourage c'est quelque chose de
précieux
mais quand on atteint l'autosuffisance
complète et que tout roule
le projet s'arrête il l'a demandé à
robin leblanc qui a depuis rêva lui et
certaines productions
même si ces techniques que sont bien
rodés qu'il sait quoi faire quand le
faire et surtout quoi éviter à l'époque
en fait de toute suffisance l'a
quasiment à 100%
c'était bien pour faire des expériences
était de découvrir les commentaires
qu'on fait du sirop d'érable ça se fait
comment du fromage comment se conserve
on apprenait finalement donné à deux
trois ans quand on commence à répéter
des choses c'est plus une nouvelle
expérience
ça fait que j'ai vraiment fait de tri je
me suis dit qu'est ce que j'aime
vraiment faire robin a ainsi décidé
d'abandonner la production de blé
si beaucoup trop de travail tout comme
traire une vache chaque matin on a
dessiné un peu plus de s'orienter vers
des échanges communautaires c'est à dire
que si un producteur proche qui produit
du lait
nous on peut transformer et à ce moment
là on peut se changer les produits
transformés excellence aux séquelles
sortes de fromages en fait c'est aussi
d'échanger des connaissances ensemble
que tout montre sans bénéfices et
d'autosuffisance personnel à
autosuffisance communautaire l'idée fait
son chemin
ici on passe un coup de gueule inapte
pour aérer le sol
c'est un seul ou les pôles ont passé
toutes les ventes du 1er novembre
aujourd'hui à sainte lucie des
laurentides dominique la montagne est
devenu l'une des voix militante des
artisans fermiers pour une agriculture
d'autosuffisance je trouve que le terme
autosuffisance fait peur aux gens des
fois ils pensent que c'est tout ou rien
alors qu'au contraire une autosuffisance
partiel c'est une belle façon de
commencer à assurer sa pérennité
d'abord une certaine résilience en code
problème dans ce qu'il appelle la ferme
impossible il élève poules chèvres et
cultive des légumes de serre
si on est à cinq cents mètres d'altitude
on est en zone 3 ha et encore de la
neige à la mi mai c'est des forêts de
conifères ya beaucoup de bouche la terre
est pas nécessairement très agréable on
a décidé dès le début de faire nos
potagers dans une grande serre parce que
la saison est beaucoup trop courte or
jamais tomates si le mur si tu lisais
lève pas dans un environnement contrôlé
assez rapidement je me suis rendu compte
que si on y arrivait ici nous c'était
quelque chose qui allait pouvoir est
imité par beaucoup beaucoup de monde
dominique la montagne a publié des
livres et donner des conférences pour
partager son expérience mais aussi pour
exiger des changements législatifs et
une ouverture des systèmes de quotas qui
laisse peu de place aux petits
producteurs et artisans fermiers pour
lui une véritable autosuffisance
alimentaire passe davantage par une
multitude de petits producteurs ou
citoyens capables de produire quelque
chose dans leur communauté que par de
grandes productions concentré dans
quelques mains
on parle par exemple de produire du miel
mais moi je vous préférez le modèle où
tout le monde produit un peu de miel à
sa façon avec son petit extracteur de
miel avec sa petite ruche qu'un modèle
où tout le monde convergeraient vers une
grande galerie
je pense que plus les gens ont chacun le
petit modèle plus on est redondant
finalement plus on est fort
[Musique]
je pense qu'il y en a un mouvement ça
serait encore plus fun de le voir
vraiment partout que ce soit c'est
d'actualité mais que ce soit vraiment
une norme sociale qui pose juste une
mode quelque chose qui se maintient à
long terme
la crise sanitaire provoque une remise
en question de la chaîne alimentaire
les idées les souhaits et même les
discours politiques encouragent
d'autosuffisance mais est ce que cela
sera dur et personnellement je ne sais
pas trouvé à roue ça va évoluer tout ça
s'est relativement jeunes comme crise
moi mon sentiment quand je vois sur les
réseaux sociaux passer des résolutions
de personnes qui se disait c'est
vivement le tenue mais alimentaire jeu
ça justement la résolution du premier de
l'an chassez le naturel il revient au
galop
ça c'est la ricotta on peut ressortir
quelque chose de cette crise là dessus
on peut s'en sortir et dire bon en 2020
qu'est ce qui nous manquait peut-être
avant la crise
c'était peut être socialement de se
connaître un peu plus d'aller voir un
producteur de voir un sourire sur le
visage de quelqu'un de comprendre ces
difficultés de voir comment est-ce qu'on
peut s'entraider et d'avoir un milieu
social un peu plus riches
[Musique]